if you have a vaccine we're back to
business but without the back green I
think it's I don't know man I think it
could be a while I think I'm gonna tell
you something - I think this [ __ ] was I
think I honestly don't think that this
is an accident this is not a bat in a
[ __ ] soup well what is it talk to me
I think that this was a plan man I think
by who
first of all this came out in January of
20 they drop the [ __ ] like an album this
came out in January of 2020 this book he
came out January 2020 yeah you know this
doctor made a good point it's not
attacking young people it's attacking
weaker people it's attacking older
people people that you know so if you
want to talk I mean listen I'm not
trying to get into a conspiracy thing
but there's a lot of the conspiracy bro
let's do it there and I open that third
eye dog I heard a doctor say something
really interesting and I'll send you the
link he said it's almost as if looking
at this virus it was modified to not hit
young people think about that he said
young people have weaker lungs and a
weaker immune system that's immature and
not developed yet yet they're walking
through it like it doesn't happen but
you're 75 and older with any conditions
wiped out he's like there could be
something to that plus the first handful
of cases that came out were next to
their biotech labs miles away from the
biotech lab in China and Wuhan is away
from from their virus bacteria chemical
lab right there those are the first
cases which were right near that fish
market so you know I mean who knows mark
just called it the Wuhan ik plague
[Laughter]